[Music]
this is Washington DC's streetcar it
runs through about 2.2 miles of mixed
traffic in the United States capital and
it was once a part of an ambitious 37
mile streetcar network for the city but
those plans have changed drastically the
project was delivered seven years past
its deadline and tens of millions of
dollars over budget the idea was to
increase mobility for residents while
revitalizing an economically depressed
area of the city but it's had trouble
along the way similar problems rung up
in Atlanta in Salt Lake City too still
there's a massive resurgence of
streetcars underway since 2001
about a dozen streetcar systems have
cropped up across the country but why do
so many cities want streetcars the
general goal is based on the idea that
if we build more densely around our
transit stations then we'll convince
more people to walk around the bike
around and take transit to get to work
to get to school and hit our other
destinations streetcars are also touted
for the ability to add a certain janessa
quoi to a neighborhood you know every
city in the country even around the
world wants to have some type of train
going through their cities because they
see it as a positive modern looking and
modern feeling public transportation
system the case for building streetcars
has historical precedent they've been
around since the 19th century when they
were first horse driven and later in the
20th century
the electrical versions became really
popular in cities their popularity
started to fade when cities turned their
focus to building infrastructure for
buses and cars but in the last decade or
so streetcars have made a comeback
there's been a lot of excitement and
enthusiasm about urban living some of
that comes with excitement about mass
transit mass transportation but big sort
of traditional heavy rail subway
projects are very very expensive so
cities look for something cheaper that
they can do and a lot of them have come
up with streetcars the portland
streetcar was one of
first in the new wave and has led the
way for other cities its success is
often cited in proposals to exemplify
the benefits of a modern transit system
but all shriek our proposals are not
created equal some have seen roaring
success while others like in Atlanta in
DC see a ton of criticism the problem is
is that having sort of gone for mass
transit on the cheap
you get transit that isn't very useful
for transportation it looks nice you
have this cool shiny new train but if
you're running in mixed traffic you're
gonna go as slow or oftentimes slower
than a traditional bus aside from the
slow pace limited connectivity has kept
commuters away in DC I've been living
here for 37 years and I like the
streetcar I like it cuz it's convenient
no only thing I don't like about it is
it doesn't go far enough bus take me
straight to my jobs right in front of my
job the streetcar don't even go over the
yield which I didn't think made sense
but so if they're not improving the
commute why is there a push for more
streetcars from my perspective they are
almost entirely designed to support
economic development and not increase
mobility in Portland for instance
planners actively sought development
adjacent to the streetcar our narrative
is was pretty development focused early
on to the point where people were saying
the only the only reason you've built
the streetcar was for development
purposes now that we're carrying upwards
of 16 thousand passengers a day it's
very much a mix the system succeeded
because Portland speed car worked with
developers to support their plan you
have to really look at the development
side of things having the rail in the
ground is significantly important for
them to see the commitment from the city
for them to make catalytic investments
is important right they're asking these
developers to build something that they
may not build anyway but for the rail
investment so there's a there's a little
bit of a quid pro quo there
that kind of focus on economic
development is at the heart of other
projects to the BQ X's be a
state-of-the-art streetcar that runs
from a story at a Sunset Park and has
the potential to generate over 25
billion dollars of economic activity for
our city over 30 years projections aside
the brooklyn-queens connector has
already proven to be a contentious issue
one clear reason why the project has
been advanced is is similar to the
streetcar projects being discussed
around the country which is that there's
an economic development goal in the
Brooklyn and Queens waterfront by some
major investors who want to improve
transportation for basically the new
towers that are being constructed along
the waterfront the motivation behind
development and its effects make for a
messy debate a year after its launch DC
is starting to see the development that
tends to follow transit a string of
luxury apartments restaurants and stores
have fueled a real estate boom along
each street I think there is evidence
that suggests that government
expenditures of any sorts that provide a
public benefit will provide sort of a
stimulus for development whether they're
investments in neighborhood retail
improvement whether they're better
sidewalks but it doesn't have to be a
streetcar there are many ways to attract
new investment and the streetcar may not
be the ideal one or even the right one
you
[Music]